The Maricopa County vote drop.
It is about 98,000 ballots.
It's the largest one.
What we can tell you
is that Katie Hobbs still mainta
her lead over Carrie Lake.
She is maintaining a lead
of about 48,000 votes.
Now, that margin is tighter
it is smaller than it was here
in Maricopa County.
The versus the last report.
The last report had that margin
at about 57,000.
Now it's 48,000.
So Lake
does advance makes that margin
a little bit tighter.
But Hobbs maintains her lead.
What we are
now told by Maricopa County
and we're doing some loose math
they have just
under 100,000 ballots left.
So not that many ballots left.
100,000
They are moving very, very rapid
Now that the processing has been
They simply have to tabulate
that they anticipate
that they will get through the l
bulk of these ballots by tomorro
So tomorrow night,
they are going to have
another vote release.
But right now,
I can tell you, Paula,
that we are seeing this race tig
The margin is a little smaller.
But Katie Hobbs maintains her le
She is a Democrat running for go
Still over the Republican
who is running for governor, Cor
And what is particularly interes
about this, Paula,
is that in talking to the Lake c
they are putting their eggs
into this basket.
They anticipated a huge swing.
They were very
there was a lot of bravado
and social media
saying that tonight was a night
that they were going to take the
That did not happen here
in Maricopa County.
The bulk of the votes,
the largest vote
bulk, is here in this county.
It is the most populous county
in the state of Arizona.
And what the Lake campaign
had been anticipating
simply did not happen, though
she did advance.
Still, 100,000 votes left to cou
And we just have to see how that
Mark Preston, what stands out to
Well, a couple of things.
One is,
I mean,
if we think overall
and we look at this election
the election deniers seem to by
to have seemed to have lost
and those who have lost
their races have conceded.
So that's
why we're all looking at Arizona
right now,
because the biggest election den
one of the loudest voices about
of course, is Carrie Lake.
And she's the Republican nominee
for governor in Arizona.
Here's the situation, though.
While she did
gain some ground right there,
we think that she expected
to get much more ground gained.
And now
the pie is starting to shrink ri
And for her
path to win is getting smaller.
I don't think
we're going to call this race to
There's still a hundred thousand
votes out in Maricopa County.
We saw 93,000 just dropped right
And then we have the current two
to call,
as well as the election official
say, Paula.
Let's just all take a deep breat
and let the the officials do the
Well said. Well said.
But it seems like she
I mean,
even as these officials
our are doing their work,
she has been sowing doubt.
And you have had officials
in Arizona, Democrats
and Republicans, complimenting e
about the important work
that they're doing and the fair
that they're doing.
So you are seeing this kind of p
in real time
to the disinformation
that she and her campaign
are trying to spread,
even as the votes
aren't even counted yet. Right.
It's interesting
to see
all those people
come together against this commo
enemy, disinformation, false cla
Well,
they've been through this rodeo
particularly in Maricopa, County
I mean, they were kind of ground
One of the several is the grand
I guess, and in the last electio
So I think there's an acknowledg
of how fast
and how
united that
they have to be to push back on
as it's coming in. Absolutely. N
If Republicans take the House,
I mean, how much will
their internal squabbling,
their infighting matter
in terms of actually
getting anything done?
Does it matter if you have the m
if you're fighting among yoursel
I mean,
I think we all are watching this
in real time.
Kevin McCarthy,
it sounds like the Freedom
Caucus is going to make his life
from go.
I mean, look at John Boehner,
former Speaker John Boehner.
What he had to deal with, less
so with Paul Ryan.
Paul Ryan had to deal with that
a little bit.
But it seems like as the margins
the more you have to pay attenti
to every section of your confere
I mean, I know you covered this
It has been. It is.
We're already
seeing these challenges form
and they're not going to make hi
easier That's for sure.
They have no incentive to
no incentive at all.
And in clear,
the control of the Senate
is very important.
And going into these races, thou
a lot of people thought
that President Biden was
was really a liability
for the candidates.
But how much credit does he dese
for the Senate control?
Well,
a lot of Democrats are giving hi
credit, including Senator
Elizabeth Warren.
I think today was out there sayi
that Democrats should credit him
because of the fact that he was
really crystallizing.
They think the argument
heading into the final stretch.
A lot of people did doubt
what he was focusing on
and Biden was focusing on what h
his administration had been doin
they think, to help
Americans pocketbooks,
but also abortion access
and threats to democracy.
Those were two of the biggest ar
from the president
and from a number of other Democ
And there was a question
about whether or not
those two focuses would actually
vulnerable Democrats.
Now, I although some of the poll
always show that
that was top of mind for voters
when I was traveling in Michigan
and when I was talking to some v
in Pennsylvania,
it was very clear
that abortion access
was front and center
for a lot of those voters in Mic
There was a ballot measure,
an abortion ballot measure in th
along with four other states.
But in Pennsylvania,
some of the voters
that I was talking to in the lea
were saying
that they were squarely focused
on abortion. It was motivating D
And they also brought up democra
and their fear
about all of these election lies
That was a common theme,
as Mark mentioned, across states
It wasn't just in Arizona.
There were election deniers
up and down the ballot.
In Michigan,
there were some in Pennsylvania.
And across the board,
they appear to have lost.
I don't think that
that means, though, that electio
are going to go away at all
because we see that
the former president
is continue
continuing to spread those lies.
But it does speak to candidate q
Right.
That's one of the reasons
that these
these people could go the distan
And in some cases,
you had national Republicans
pull their money,
not support, but support them.
But in other cases,
they were all in
just to grow their numbers.
I should say one more thing
about Kevin McCarthy.
He did bring this on himself
when you had all of the fringe m
of his of the conference
doing things that were sort of
out of the norm, to say the leas
throughout the last conference,
instead of,
you know,
taking them in
and saying this is inappropriate
we shouldn't be doing this.
He brought them into the fold.
And he, you know, by
by allowing that to happen,
by not having any sort of discip
I know it sounds like
something out of school or somet
but by not having any sort of st
like that, he empowered them
and that's where he's at.
That's really interesting now.
Let's let's look ahead to Georgi
You have been on the ground
reporting in that state.
You would know better than anybo
What does it mean
if Raphael Warnock picks takes t
What is that one extra Senate se
Mean for the Biden administratio
and its agenda?
I think it's pivotal.
I think that,
you know,
some are trying to sort of downp
its significance
because Georgia is not again
going to be in the position
to determine the Senate majority
but it's still huge.
We have seen that
there are at least two senators
who are not Democratic senators
who are not reliably reliable
Democratic votes.
Right.
Senator Manchin,
Senator Cinema, that that
is leads
to less pressure
on Senator Schumer
to have to persuade them.
If you have Senator Warnock,
who has proved to be
a much more reliable Democratic
And then also,
when you're thinking about confi
of judges,
President Biden
being able to move his appointee
that helps as well.
But also,
I think it's important
for the state of Georgia.
You know, Senator
Warnock, Herschel Walker
have been running their campaign
very differently
they're very different candidate
And really key
to Senator Warnock's reelection
is that he is willing to work
with Republicans. Right.
We are living in a very polarizi
and we don't hear that a lot.
We don't hear candidates center
to their reelection argument
that they want to work
with the other party.
And so does this work?
Is he successful?
Is he able to peel off
independents and moderates
with this election argument?
I think that is a big test.
You know, it's interesting, too,
if you really want to get great
into Joe Biden
as Joe Biden think, who is Joe B
He was asked this question yeste
when he's overseas,
an extremely important trip.
And they said,
what does this mean, this Georgi
And he said it means more
committee assignments.
And what that means
is actually more power
within the United States
Senate for Democrats as a whole.
But it just goes to show you tha
that that Joe Biden, president,
vice president,
he's really an institutional ass
He really is a senator
more than anything.
So as as we try to move
forward, as Republicans are tryi
you know,
get their act together on the Hi
Can Joe Biden go in and cut deal
with Mitch McConnell, other Repu
in his final two years?
Because that's the only way
he's going to get anything
done is his ability
to try to come to the center.
And on that committee power
that you're talking about,
it also means subpoena power. Ri
Which Democrats don't have right
that 50 50 Senate.
It would be if there's a House R
and then
House Republicans in power
and dueling with Senate Democrat
in terms of investigations.
That's another thing that we cou
if Georgia goes to Democrats.